we are following breaking news tonight
there is a major police presence right
near the d.i desert in underpass near
the strip it has been impacting traffic
at this hour this is a live look and
again it is back open in that area
eastbound and westbound that happened
about an hour and a half ago good
evening to you thanks for joining us at
six i'm brian loftis i'm denise valdez
let's get right out to mary jane
billyessa and mary jane what are you
seeing right now
yeah well good evening denise and brian
we are standing here on the intersection
of the convention center and las vegas
boulevard we're actually on top of the
desert and tunnel as you can see traffic
is moving smoothly here after police
activity
was spotted here earlier and police shut
it down but now it's open we're still
trying to confirm exactly what led up to
it witnesses tell 8 news now they saw
police with guns drawn right before the
tunnel heading westbound on desert inn
but it has since reopened and it does
seem like traffic is moving smoothly
there is one police car still there
again we're trying to confirm those
details of what happened so make sure
you stay with us here live and on air
with eight news now as we continue to
bring you the latest updates on air and
online reporting live here on the
intersection of las vegas boulevard and
the convention center mary jane balleza
live local now